foreign
[Music]
out in Austin he hit up Rachel on
Instagram and was like Hey I want to buy
Eric a cowboy hat can you tell me his
size and Rachel being Rachel was like oh
well here's his size but you know what
would be really great is if you got me a
hat too like it can't just be about me
you know what I mean and I didn't know
this and he didn't tell me he shows up
with the hats and I'm like oh man this
is great man thank you you know what I
mean look you know guy now look at that
that looks good it ain't bad huh I get
home and I want a surprise Rachel and
I'm like babe turn around take it out of
my bag I put my hat on and then I'm
holding her hat and she turns around and
she's like oh yay then she tells me
she's like well I already knew you
already knew you got me doing this whole
surprise thing and you already knew